I Sam and this is Sam he runs
what's the shop called now for poor
shorty I've known Sam for years we've
been on road trips together we've had a
lot of fun so I always like to visit
when I can and kind of show off what the
shop does so over here we can see
definitely all the fire-spinning
products mmm wicks and various sizes and
shapes the ISIS heads are probably my
favorite from the fire plywood use and
it's really a full full-fledged
and we've got things here like in
Germany you shipped us all over Europe
kind of it yeah some of them yes some of
them no but you can see it in the shock
when you when you take the destination
the country yeah it says yes or no
whether you can order it or not this one
we can ship almost everywhere because
there's a definition of dangerous yeah
61 degrees and this one is 62 yeah it's
know you can it's like olive oil or
butter it does burn but it's no problem
we use it for indoor shows and for
everything so in Canada typically what
people seem to choose from is either you
miss Coleman camp fuel white gas which
is extremely volatile so it's kind of
dangerous or the lamp oil we can get in
North America which is really stinky
this is a nice what's technically is it
it's kind of lamp oil but it's very
cleaned right and it doesn't stink at
all yeah it doesn't smoke that much so
it never happens you have to clean the
toys anymore and and also you can it's
very yeah yes no it doesn't sink yeah
all right so this is something I wish we
had this in Canada because basically
it's safe the way our lamp oil is but it
burns cleaner and less stinky so it's
kind of the best of both worlds so if
you're in Germany and Europe
you can actually order this and have it
shipped to you we have been different
this is the blue 62 yeah and this is 56
which says it wants a little bit faster
we got the same is 42 okay for the
wintertime because in the winter time of
course it takes a little than you it's
better to take we have the pure flow it
for fire freezing yeah
which nobody should do in my opinion
because it's really really dangerous but
if people do it at least they should
take left because you don't get cancer
okay
still when you swallow it you have
problems or dying cool and we also have
of course like a podium which is I've
only got to play with a few times but
it's like a powder from flour that that
when you in this form it doesn't it
won't light but once it's in the air is
a powder it puffs in a huge flame yeah
yeah so all kinds of Sam really started
as a performer so and they still do
shows as a very big part of what they do
so there's all it's all kinds of
performance things so this this you can
do any kind of fire sculpture with
so it's really good if you want to do
like hot so any virus yeah yeah make
shape so you can do really good for a
finale yeah 20 years that's right the
sauce is just it's for
extension some people like to make
extensions and you never know if they
make one or two or three so we said no
we make a lot and then we can just cut
it but we call it the poi sausage yeah
so when you want to construct something
and what's really popular now is Isaac
yeah I don't know what's called iron
powder I don't know yet so we sell a lot
it makes some sparkling yeah
yeah I'd actually I'll be a customer no
no no I just switched to a much smaller
so I have to everything's got to be very
small yeah all right cool
yeah basically that's it okay we have
some new plants but they are not not
ready yet there's a yeah check out the
shop and you can you can put playboy if
you if you get something and then Sam
will know I'm sending some customers and
Sampson very supportive of my pores and
a lot of stuff so and I really
appreciate that so it's always good to
visit okay